[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to the lobby
game spots weekly video game hangout i'm
mike mccarty your host
it is 11am here on wednesday what day is
it march 1st first day of march so you
say this is pete brown i've lost all the
sense of time yeah you've been playing
zelda for what like six straight days
kind of yeah something like that you
have a catheter in right now
yeah i'm used to it now though yeah like
an iv drip no
your dog's been feeding you
enough of that cali plaguey what's up
hey what's going on other much i played
zelda yesterday
for the first time well i mean apart
from uh e3 demos everything but yeah uh
thank you everyone for joining uh
whether you're through twitch or youtube
or gamespot we have the chat up here so
for all intents purposes you are here
with us we are going to be monitoring
the chat i have a lot of questions about
a lot of huge topics today through
twitter uh that we tweeted out earlier
we have a giveaway which i'll get to in
a second we have a few news items but
yeah today we'll be talking horizon zero
dawn again the embargo lifted like two
weeks ago but we're just gonna kind of
do
one last finally out this week one last
q a for pete who reviewed it and uh
myself and kelly also played a lot of it
uh zelda as much as we could talk about
zelda i'm going to kind of depend on you
for what yeah i shouldn't say so if i
say anything that breaks embargo tell me
afterward once i've already broken it
okay
sound good i'm kidding i'm not gonna
spoil anything for breaking bargain
like proper downs and stuff like that
and yeah this guy in this green tune
well he doesn't he's not a green team at
this time that joke doesn't work i'm so
hap well yeah i guess we can't even talk
about certainly this guy whose name is
not zelda
we'll figure out we'll come up with like
a student we could talk about names what
are you talking about um and then we're
also going to be doing our final
nintendo switch impressions we have our
review up right the review of the switch
is up yes jimmy zelda will be live
tomorrow jimmy our tech editor did our
nintendo switch review that is up
we all looked it over and uh you know
we've got our own impressions though
we'll talk about that and
middle earth shadow of war leaked
so we're gonna well it leaked and then
it was announced and then there's
gameplay coming next week so we're gonna
get into that what we want from it i
loved the first game but first we have a
giveaway um gamespot in a few minutes is
gonna tweet something about a gunner
glasses gunner optics i think you might
call them computer eyewear computer
eyewear i'll give that to pete so you
can model that to where um
gamespot is gonna tweet so follow a
gamespot if you don't already on twitter
uh retweet the tweet about this giveaway
and then in a few days we will pick a
winner and you will get these in the
mail uh i believe this is us only
apologize apologies to our uk australia
the only other country
i could list all what 235 i think and
i'm going to give this razer mouse to
cali to show off that is also part of
the giveaway so like i said uh retweet
we'll pick it in a few days uh
someone in the chat is correcting you
saying his name isn't zelda kelly i said
his name wasn't zelda that's literally
what i said i think the joke went over
this person's head uh
yeah that's right i'm a fake geek
um cool so that's the giveaway yeah like
i said i'll bring that back up at the
end of the episode just to remind you
who are here now and to bring it back up
for people later but a few news items i
want to get through
uh
peter moore
former ea ceo is now
ceo of liverpool football club in the
premier league cool i guess that makes
sense i mean from a business perspective
uh that's actually i was joking to chris
beaumont uh he's like head of game spot
video he's a liverpool fan he's from i
don't know what part of one i think he's
from essex or something i don't know but
he's here
he's an actual liverpool fan and i was
talking to him about this but i grew up
in liverpool new york right outside of
syracuse so like when i had to watch
soccer i always said i was a liverpool
fan
it was like my my this is too much
information but my dad grew up in
cleveland new york so he always liked
the cleveland browns
yeah i'm gonna keep going there's a
mexico new york there's a rome new york
people from upstate new york if you're
here texas there's a paris texas we live
in the paris of the west
they've called san francisco that before
but yeah he's becoming
yeah they ea's peter moore leaving to
become ceo his favorite soccer team the
news story is up on gamespot uh
he will soon join them uh let me i'm
reading through it now he's set to move
to liverpool and begin his new role with
the team in june team announces his
website today moore's a lifelong fan of
the team was born liverpool i don't
think there's any news yet about who's
gonna replace him right
i don't know do you want to
now that you know zelda how many uh ea
sport that's in the game jokes were in
the comments of that story let me check
[Music]
i don't know
we have that like infinite scroll for
news stories
uh
gubeshu raya is
talking about syracuse in the chat i
don't think he actually graduated from
sarah you think he's making fun of me uh
but yeah ea had a whole statement which
i don't feel the need to read because
pretty pr speak peter has been with us
for here at ea for nearly 10 years and i
consider myself privileged to have said
who is this that's talking about this oh
andrew andrew wilson is saying this um
yeah
yeah so it's just he's going to
liverpool in june
that's enough of that uh and then just
for a minor thing if you play the
division if you're a fan the last stand
dlc is out now for all platforms so you
can play that it is uh
focused on
new more challenging dark zone north
area as well as a pvp mode called last
stand the mode which is basically
organized pvp in the dark zone pits
teams of eight against each other and
supports matchmaking a new incursion
stolen signal
and yeah just more dangerous dark zone
i haven't played much of that game
recently but if you're a division fan
it's probably not bad uh here's the
transition into our first segment
the other day target on their
international website
leaked middle earth shadow of war which
uh we've kind of known the sequels in
the works for shadow of mordor the 2014
game for a while
um i mean it wasn't it was like people
suspected if it was nothing confirmed so
now target accidentally leaked it and
then yesterday i believe warner bros was
like yeah this is an official thing we
came in in the morning they said yeah
middle earth shadow of war is the thing
uh
they showed the trailer off i guess like
to coincide with gdc this week in san
francisco
and it looks pretty cool i don't
you're not a tolkien fan kelly i don't
are you pete you're not super into
talking stuff
i read the books as a kid okay i like
the movies two degrees but no not
hardcore you dabbled in the game right
in 2014 shadow
that's being generous yeah yeah yeah i
know very little about lord of the rings
okay it was my favorite game of 2014 so
i wanted to talk about kind of what to
expect or what we want in shadow of war
mike what do you want in shadow what do
i want so i think the thing that the
game is most known for the first game is
the nemesis system which i'm sure you
not having played the game you're still
probably familiar with it it was great
at the time it's uh cool or still it was
you know you fight this one orc leader
and uh depending on how you kill him
he'll he could come back later and have
like a grudge against you or beef with
another orc leader and you can kind of
pit them against each other
in this open world
and it actually felt like you were kind
of molding things depending on your
actions so now they're saying you're
actually going to shape the world
that could be just like you know that's
a marketing broad
statement super broad
and kind of bold i guess maybe not bold
but
how are we actually going to shape this
world is what i'm wondering they say
there's a new stronghold system so i
wonder
if like the factions will be affected
more from how you take down specific
outposts and whatnot because that's a
big part right you're this ranger
italian and you're going around mordor
with keller brimbore here uh he's a
wraith now but he's originally the elf
who uh crafted or helped craft the
original ring of power but in this
trailer it shows that you are
you know like italian and calibrimbor
were kind of fused and he's now part
wraith part undead ranger uh after
having died in the first game which is
not really a spoiler it happens right at
the beginning
uh and you know sauron's back this whole
trailer showing sauron for those who
don't know he's the dark lord he's the
evil dude
i knew that lava and that
massive helmet isn't telling you but so
you're crafting your own ring of power
to rival him
um it looks awesome
i loved the first game more than i can
explain uh
i don't want to get into that
on a different segment maybe but i
am really
what i want is for the world actually to
react to me like they're saying it is
but
i want the strongholds to kind of
change based on what i do at each one uh
not just the nemesis system i want that
to be somehow factored into the world
because it was really impressive how
that worked in the first game you know
you get those you get that little like
checkerboard of
orcs it shows this like an experienced
tree almost but with like the orc
leaders and you know depending on how
you kill this one that'll affect this
one's status and you essentially are
like pushing this one guy up to the top
so you can assassinate him and take out
the faction it was great
and i actually i want that to work with
the strongholds you know not just the
enemies um
so of your brief time with the first
game like what did you play like an hour
or two yeah
did you
like the open world at all
i mean the little i saw of it yes uh
mobility is something that i like really
highly value in games and i remember
correctly the character was pretty good
at like scaling walls and being kind of
like stealthy and sneaking around and
but covering ground and stuff so that
felt really good like the movement felt
great and watching other people play it
looked like you definitely unlock a lot
of powers that make you more swift
and then lethal um so i i found like
things that were interesting to me but
it was just at a point in time where i
didn't i wasn't ready to play
a game you know be because of
assignments or whatever
um
the mobility was great uh there was this
one movie unlocked later on where you
land and then you tap a button and he
does this dash so
you could fast travel but you it felt
kind of too good it was almost like not
as good as like sunset overdrive or
something but
i didn't want to fast travel because it
felt so good to move around right and
the stealth mechanics worked the stealth
and the combat were kind of you know
like to name the game that kind of
started this trend it was the arkham
asylum combat right the attack encounter
system with a few other things thrown in
but
the
you know the dichotomy between the
wraith attacks and the ranger attacks
was what really drove this game i think
aside from the nemesis system which was
the drawing factor and i want to see
more of that especially now that you
have your own ring of power
i want to just be able to be completely
overpowered at the end of the game
because
even at the end of shadow of mordor in
2014 i didn't ever feel overpowered at
the end because
these orcs were becoming so good the
nemesis ones they scaled to you yeah
and i actually kind of want that i want
them to
make me feel like i actually have a ring
of power i don't want it to be just this
narrative device i wanted to be this
thing fueling my abilities right because
it used to be just ranger abilities or
wraith abilities uh now i actually want
to just be like
blowing this [ __ ] up people essentially
you just want to blow a bunch of people
is what you just
blow the [ __ ] out of people which is
still not a good term i don't know if
you're in the chat uh let me know if
what you want to see in shadow of war
you meant blow up yes
uh i have a question so
not about that goddamn both of you
um
i like to joke that my extent uh the
extent of my lord of the rings knowledge
is the several led zeppelin songs about
the rings oh yeah so gallon and the evil
one yeah ramble on et cetera et cetera
so uh
thank you
so uh my question is what like should i
even care if i don't know anything about
lord of the rings like what's the draw
there for like you're a super fan what's
the draw there for me um
so i don't know
whether you could jump in with this game
uh you could jump into lord of the rings
with shadow of mordor you could play
shadow mortar without needing to worry
about tolkien backstory uh they do a
really good job of using tolkien's world
as you know backstory but having a
really good self-contained story in
itself uh is it canon or is it not canon
it's
canon they use
the actual events aren't canon but they
use they use like
a real character the elf calibrimbor is
a real character he like helped forge
the ring of power but
i don't believe these games are canon
and i could be completely wrong but from
playing through that uh i think it was
four or three years ago who's just it
wasn't anymore
yeah
right tolkien's son is still alive and
kind of controls like the publishing and
like all of that they're super strict
it's actually crazy how close to not
being made shadow mordar was because of
how strict the tolkien estate is with
everything
sidewinder 2057 does not care shadow of
who give a [ __ ]
uh it's not canon thank you apex penguin
i i didn't think so but they are using
real characters calibrimbor is a real
character um so it's so the the
lore itself the backdrop is is all in
line with
okay that's basically it right uh so yes
to answer your question i think you
could easily are you asking if you could
just jump in with shadow mordor to get
ready for this
you don't need extended token knowledge
what is in shadow of mortar for someone
like me who doesn't who just wants to
listen to led zeppelin all day
uh turn that on while you play it'd
probably be a fun time but yeah like
i think the open world itself you
thought i thought it'd be boring right
these muted colors but then there's
another part of it later on that's
pretty lush uh mordor despite the fact
that you think of all this you know
volcanic igneous rocks are there big
spiders
yeah i believe so are there trees that
walk
i don't think there are ants no um are
there uh is there a guy who talks to
himself in the cave
gollum yeah yeah he's in it i'm i'm
really exaggerating how little i know i
know that his name is coming it's gone
yeah yeah because uh they mentioned
gollum and ramble on so would you say
that you want shadow of war to kind of
just build on chat of mordor without
making you feel excluded for not knowing
much about tolkien yeah like i guess my
big concern is like
hearing you talk about how much you love
this game like i want to give it a shot
but i'm worried that i will be too basic
for it
yeah i know it
i love the game for reasons completely
separate from my tolkien fandom uh
we don't have a lexa ray career here
anymore she was the tolkien
like genius here at gamespot before she
went on to new projects but she was also
always the one talking about how
this game did a great job of
like i said uh having a self-contained
story within tolkien's world but you
know not necessarily uh pushing you away
if you don't care about tolkien i like
the game for reasons apart from that i
love the game for the nemesis system how
it reacts to you i hope in shadow of war
that they actually
make good on that promise to you know
kind of the world being shaped yeah at
your hand
a lot of games say they're gonna do that
but we'll see if shadow of war actually
does it's coming out in august it's not
crazy far away super tough yeah before
we know it yeah that will especially
because everything leading up to that is
crazy like through march we have a lot
of releases especially with the nintendo
switch launching which we're going to
get to for those of you who are
open world games are coming this year i
don't know we because last year was
actually kind of
sparse for memorial games for once and
and that's you're talking to the no
no no but
compared to like years before that yeah
last year there was like five which is
not much being the person who reviewed
most of them felt like a lot yeah
and it would be if like they didn't just
dominate games now yeah um
we are going to be talking about breath
of the wild a little bit and
i think breath of the wild would be a
breath of
fresh air legend of zelda the breath of
the fresh air you're the first person to
make that joke mike i'm not i know
anyway um
yeah so if you're watching this on
youtube or game spot let us know in the
comments and whatnot we're still reading
the chat but let us know what you want
in shadow of war uh details are kind of
sparse we're gonna see game play on
march 8th before uh we might see more
stuff leading up to its august release
i'm sure we will but yeah it's official
warner bros announced it target leaked
it the other day nice job target thank
you uh you can watch the trailer it's up
on gamespot right now you can
check out more from the game i think you
should play shadow mordor if you have
not yet uh there are a lot of games
coming out but shadow of mordor is still
a fantastic game how long does it take
to play shadow motor 30 hours 30 i just
say that's good
100 maybe 35 40. to do the salt thing
yeah
so let us know what you think
all right
we have talked
a lot about horizon zero dawn
let's keep going let's keep going uh we
stopped doing these just like straight
up asked the reviewers like q a but we
figured it was pertinent because again
we've talked about so much but now the
game's out came out yesterday despite
the fact that we it's been lauded all
over the place for about two weeks now i
love it cali i love it i can't stop
playing it actually it's really good
um pete you reviewed it you gave it a
nine out of ten yeah uh we have a lot of
questions for you i'm gonna let you kick
it off though what do you love about
this game
boo where to begin uh i think combat is
sort of first and foremost the the best
part about the game eloy is uh super
agile right she uh and she fights these
like monsters that are really machines
that are super fast and they always sort
of have an answer for everything that
you throw at them so you're constantly
juggling this really diverse set of
tools
facing off enemies that have a diverse
set of abilities and trying to sort of
just come out on top but you also have a
chance to be creative with the stuff
that you have and so really like the
flow of combat and being able to mix
things up and do things differently
um
and the diversity of the monsters
themselves like as you explore the map
you run into a lot of crazy variations
and uh
you know combat is really the thing that
drives this game home but it's also a
very beautiful world and eloy is a
really great character like she's you
know she's not perfect like there's some
dialogue that feels a bit you know like
sort of just drummed up for side quests
and stuff like okay but as a character
like she starts off as someone who
doesn't know a lot about the world but
she comes into something to own
something that no one else really has
ownership of or knowledge of
and that sort of propels her down this
path where she begins to just be the
only person who really gets what's going
on in the world and has mastery over it
all uh so it's a really incredible
journey for that sense and yeah
throughout in the middle it's just great
combat just driving you through it we've
spoken extensively about the world
itself but it's weird i'm usually
someone who prefers
a focus on gameplay over story but when
they can mesh that's great but this is a
one of those games where this world is
awesome i mean like they we talked last
week about their unique take on the post
post apocalypse i think they're calling
it uh what is it about that blend of
nature and technology that really drives
the story and the gameplay forward
or does it i guess well it drives it
forward and so much as like no one in
the world
understands where this technology like
the you know the ruins of technology
around them came from right
so
you see stuff that looks familiar to us
you know maybe a little bit more
advanced in today's technology but like
you can't really piece together what
it's for why it's there like what
happened
and so you do piece that together over
the course of the journey and you begin
to understand sort of
how technology and science can run amok
uh especially in the hands of men right
uh not specifically males you know what
i'm saying humans and uh so
yeah like in this sort of just seeing
you know how the society you know
collapsed and how all this is viewed
from a perspective where people haven't
learned the lessons that they should
have learned from this right
and maybe there's someone sort of
stumbling down a similar path that led
to the destruction of the world you know
whatever so
um
it's kind of hard to explain without
spoiling too much but but certainly
eloy's connection to the technology and
how she uses that to
essentially piece together what happened
in the world is how those two elements
mix really well because everything is
super wild but you deal with everything
using
some form of technology or another yeah
the footage we're watching right now is
a lot of the combat um so fighting
against humans was the part that i found
pretty boring but uh yes but we did see
a lot of hunting the machines the
animals uh kelly from your time
have you encountered a lot of different
enemies and what do you think of the
combat in this game in terms of the
hunting mechanics um i i really love the
combat uh like pete said like the
movement um
aylo's movement specifically is um it
feels natural even though she's like
super agile and super um strong i don't
feel overpowered against machines but i
also don't feel like
um
like you'd think arrows you're like oh
i'm gonna it's gonna take a thousand
arrows to take down this machine um but
you get like really specific uh
like weak points um that you can target
and i i really really like that uh as an
element of combat is um kind of slowing
things down that's actually a perk you
can get and um trying to like you can
see right there pinpointing um
areas of weakness
and it it i don't know i it feels really
good um i like the slow drip of mystery
uh of like what happened to the world i
love stuff like that in general and for
this um because it's so slow and you're
doing other things and you're dealing
with tribal politics and like a lot of
the main quest is dealing with that over
dealing with the technology that you
don't know a lot about um and so i think
it all blends together really well uh i
would agree that the human combat is
probably the weakest but i had a lot of
fun stealthing my way through like
bandit camps um like i don't hate it
it's just the machines are much more
interesting because they're like
behemoths and you have to do your face
yeah you have to do a bunch of like
rolling and dodging and
setting traps on the fly and um so
that's much more exciting but i did like
the stealth element at least of fighting
humans what do you think of the actual
like open world structure as far as the
quest you're doing right because it's
made people making comparisons to a far
cry game where you're like kind of
clearing these outposts and then
unlocking parts of the map which unlocks
side quests people are kind of comparing
it to skyrim but i think that's more the
world itself uh how does the structure
of this game function overall and does
it work well
so i mean the things with like clearing
out outposts like you don't really have
to do that they're avoidable yeah i
actually chose to do only the ones that
were required of me and then after i
beat the game i went back and i was like
well i want to keep playing so i'll do
these now but but really what drove me
through the world was the idea that okay
you can you can craft a lot of really
interesting pieces of equipment um or
purchase them and you need to have a lot
of resources to do it
so you know i would find myself oh and
there's a certain item that you need
very specific items to get so basically
i was driven through the world by
wanting to find the things i need to
attain new technology right yeah i did
that too like targeting certain machines
because you need a certain part to get a
better bow or whatever it is yeah yeah
and fast travel is an option but you
know you also have the ability to hack
robots to sort of ride them through an
environment and that's really fun like
combat on horseback feels great so i
tried not to fast travel too much
through this game but i you know i
tended to avoid the things that were
maybe like
these are the missions out in the world
i actually just preferred doing the sort
of
if you can call it standard fare right
like just combat and gathering like that
was good enough for me and that i think
the game did really well mm-hmm
uh
sorry kelly you were
oh i was just gonna say um i kind of
not stumbled my way through things but i
instead of looking for things to do i
would just kind of happen upon something
and um
like i would happen upon abandoned camp
and be like oh there's you know items
here that i need i'm gonna i might as
well take it down like i found it more
natural i didn't have to
ever look for something to do i never
wanted for something to do even when i
wasn't busy with a main quest
and i do like i kind of delaying the
main quest because i just want to keep
playing and i even hunting like flesh
and blood animals for things is
right it's fun like i'm like oh i need a
boar skin so i'm gonna
find the best place to hunt boar it's a
very satisfying feeling to drawing your
bow and hitting an animal and just
gathering the thing and keeping going
but i hate killing fox you need fox
skins for
like uh for carry capacity yeah your
inventory and i love foxes and it was
really sad that i had to kill them
because they make this awful noise
especially if you yeah that's a horrible
noise especially if you um do
concentration so you slow time down
because they kind of move erratically
and the same noise a fox makes when it
dies in real life too yeah and it's like
we're ah and i'm like yeah i know yes
i chose to ignore that thank you um
yeah so i was like oh i'm so sorry
killing machines doesn't have that
effect because they're machines they
don't have souls we would probably spend
more time talking about horizon if we
hadn't already for two weeks uh pete
your review nine out of ten on gamespot
is up on gamespot yeah we also have
other things to talk about today which
everybody wants to talk about zelda
which we're coming up in like right now
uh but yeah in the meantime if you are
still interested in horizon zero dawn
uh it's worth playing i love it kelly
loves it pete loves it nine out of 10
games spot go read the review we have a
lot of coverage of it a lot of videos
guides if you're just getting into it if
you haven't picked it up yet it came out
yesterday uh go check it out game is uh
well worth the 60 it's crazy to think it
just came out yesterday it's super weird
yeah i played it like an era yes all
right on to the
game of the hour it would seem uh we
have a lot of embargo for
restrictions yeah man i am tripping up
today uh i played zelda until like
2 a.m last night uh that was my first
that was the most time i've had with the
switch too we're going to get into the
switch specifically at the end of the
show today uh we want to devote a lot of
time to zelda kind of based around the
idea of whether it feels like a zelda
game because uh from
what we've been talking about and i know
like what you know like we're right next
to giant bomb we've been talking to them
about it too
and uh
cal you're a zelda fan yes to say the
least p you are too so am i and a lot of
the things that we're all saying around
the office is that we're excited for
this game for reasons other than we
usually are for a zelda game sure yeah
for based on what we've seen what we've
played it's frankly it's the unexpected
yeah it's it's the discovery of things
you never saw coming and never realized
were possible in the game
and all that exists around you know what
appears to be a traditional zelda game
so
in my mind it kind of feels like the
best of both worlds yeah and to clarify
for people watching uh if you have
questions in youtube chat and twitch
chat gamespot uh send them our way i
have a few written down but i have a few
uh things on twitter uh pete your review
will be up can you talk about when it'll
be up yeah three a.m uh pacific time
tomorrow morning okay so it's coming in
hot
yeah early early
review uh based around i'm assuming like
japan times something like that
who knows uh yeah so 3 a.m pacific
tomorrow you can see the full review
uh pete's pretty much done with it for
the most part you got to edit it and
whatnot oh with the review yeah yeah
yeah it's
yeah right been cramming on the review
there is a lot to unpack in this game
and we can technically right now only
speak about the first five five hours
but even then there's more to talk about
this game than most games yeah i mean
that was my experience even playing
demos at e3 and stuff uh and playing a
demo or more recently is everybody
did a different thing and everyone i
talked to it was like oh i went over
here and i saw this and there was this
cute thing that happened when i
cooked and like link link comes when he
cooks and it's like the one thing that i
took away from the demo i thought was i
just love the little details right and
then everyone i talked to was like oh
well i went to a mountain and you can
freeze
like you get really cold and i'm like i
didn't even know there was a mountain i
could go to in this demo like even even
in like a 15-minute demo you have all of
that to unpack after
almost a week playing this game almost
non-stop
mike in playing it last night for just a
couple hours discovered some first 20
minutes first 20 minutes discovered
something i had never seen before can we
talk about that or not yeah okay um
that's the thing about this game i mean
aside from the survival elements aside
from just
how
enticing it is to explore i know when
the first zelda ever came out that was
like the first time people were holy
[ __ ] i want to explore every inch of
this and then ocarina came out and
showed you could do it in 3d
you know from the first five hours that
we're talking about to me it felt like i
looked out over this world this shot
right here that we're looking at it's
just like that's a promise on this games
part it's like you're gonna [ __ ] like
get wrapped up in all of this and it
does feel a little bit like a zelda game
in some of the mechanics and you know
obviously the aesthetic and the charm
and the music and a lot of what the
story that's unraveling that i am just
getting into pete you have seen much
much more than i have but yeah we we're
we're finding things continually we're
having these emergent situations we're
having these water cooler conversations
that we haven't really had since like
metal gear solid five but even not to
that this is more than that this is
something else this surpasses that and
that that game was filled with creative
opportunities right but those were
always at your hand it was sort of like
how you had control over the elements at
play and what you decided to come up
with this is almost just about
seeing things happen because of what an
enemy is doing or
something that you just never considered
before because the game doesn't tell you
yeah yeah much at all it's basically
like
all right
uh
you have to go save the princess
um you
god what what it tells you calamity
gannon has taken
go to these things to get a couple
powers i'm gonna sleep for a hundred
years you know 300 years go to these
shrines get these powers and then
basically like all right man you gotta
go and
you know like the one of the first
combat situations i got into
it was you know the thing we saw at e3
right where it's like a skull looking
like cave there's some goblins inside of
it
and i go up there with you know i found
something better than a tree branch but
it was still just like a basic club and
i roll up there and i'm trying to like
sneak and like i kill the guy on the
platform and he's got a bow and arrow
and so i try to use that but by the time
i've got that there's other goblins that
are killing me it took the first combat
encounter like the first real one took
me like three or four time tries to
solve yeah and it was because i had to
find a bow and arrow and shoot a rope to
drop an explosive thing to blow up the
barrels of the guys inside the cave
um and it's just all these little like
intricate uh
things that you have to like take care
of and consider because if you don't
you're gonna get your ass handed to you
yeah it's very easy to die in this game
both in combat and if you push yourself
too far
yeah i to go back to what we're talking
about i uh i was playing for about 20
minutes and i got a shield
uh and i had a bow you kind of just
stumble across these things you know to
clarify it's not just you don't get the
fairy bow it's not the kokiri bow you
get a bow and you're going to get like
10 more in the next 20 every single
weapon you get
you get from killing an enemy or finding
it in the field you're not going to
shops and purchasing weapons that's not
the thing yeah like that's crazy yeah
you're you're getting these abilities
with uh that chica slate that thing
that's hanging on his neck around his
belt it's kind of like the focus from
horizon zero dawn now that i think of it
the way it's framed narratively but
that's
neither here nor there um
yeah i i i had a bow i didn't have any
arrows i went up to this bokoblin camp
uh i
was holding my shield up a guy was
pointing a bow and arrow at me i was
like [ __ ] he's about to hit me and he
shot me and the arrow stuck in my shield
i was like oh that's cool
um i didn't have any arrows left so i
kind of like i just retreated because
there's four other guys i didn't want to
fight them because this game is pretty
tough and pretty unforgiving so i went
to you know like not holster but put my
shield back on my back like unequip it
to run away and i was like oh i wish the
it would have shown the arrow still in
the shield and it disappeared i was like
damn that sucks but then i was like oh
holy [ __ ] it just added that arrow that
was stuck in my shield to my inventory
yo that's so cool so i had i was talking
to pete and rob and apparently they
didn't even know that and i've been
playing 20 minutes and like we're still
seeing things that the other
how many hours have you put into it now
can you talk about at that i don't know
if i can i can't remember but you put a
lot playing it for almost a week almost
non-stop and you didn't see that or you
didn't notice it but that's the thing
there's so much [ __ ] going on this world
you're always thinking it's so it's
difficult but
i think that works right because in old
games you're i was just talking to these
npcs and zelda for the sake of it right
i was just saying i want to know more
about this world but here they tell you
useful stuff yeah like this guy has an
item that you would eventually want to
trade to him for or this person
i had this really cool moment uh
yesterday but before i was leaving the
office where uh matt and jimmy were both
playing it too
wow jimmy was having a conversation with
this person and i'm not going to get
into specifics because i want to spoil
it i don't even know if i can't talk
about this specifically but jimmy had
this conversation with this person
they had this proposal for him and he
said yeah it turned out he shouldn't
have but then matt knew not to say that
to this person because he had spoken to
this random npc in kakariko village
which is nuts
what like i don't know if it affected
the outcome but like they both had these
completely different
uh experiences within those do you have
to do the merchant
no oh it's like this clan i was talking
about right right yeah yeah and they
were talking about he's like oh holy
[ __ ] that person told you this yeah that
that's
it was it was a water cooler
conversation where they were discovering
that they both had completely different
experiences it's like uh
like when you were in school and you
would have like a playground
conversation about like
i don't know how to beat this boss how
do i do it like talking to your friends
like
when you know ocarina came out and would
be like oh you can go here and how do i
do this and like it's it's a total and
now we're seeing snowboarding which is
crazy um but the the thing i love about
it is uh
i haven't had that in a long time a lot
of times i can just kind of figure out a
game i don't necessarily need to
ask the people i know for like oh how do
i do this what's the best way to do this
and this one is like i could talk about
this for i feel like months i feel like
i'm gonna i'm gonna be playing this for
months and never see everything people
will be flooding reddit and neogaf for
years to come like with the stuff from
this game uh this is rob handler's
footage of snowboarding down a mountain
on a shield kind of legolasing uh and
then you see this kills these three and
he could have dropped a bomb here from
the paraglider right yeah but he chose
to do something way cooler yeah uh oh
he's about to do it here actually i
can't wait to talk about this game
without any restrictions yeah uh because
you've seen a ton i was watching you
play
like lit very very late game stuff and
it was crazy watching hope yeah there
you go so you could drop the remote
bombs and see you you're like a [ __ ]
bomber plane oh my god but then the
thing to the thing to consider when
you're paragliding above like a lake or
something
your stamina is running out when you're
holding it it takes energy to hold on to
that when the wind is pushing you every
which way if you fall in a lake it takes
stamina to swim you could easily drown
so you can't just aim for the middle of
a lake to negate falling damage right
yeah but at the same time maybe you can
because i found this item that is just
like bokoblin guts and i didn't think
anything of it other than oh yeah i'll
sell this maybe i'll cook it but if you
read the description
it says something along the lines of
like hmm maybe you could use this to
make something float and so i was
talking to spencer in the office about
and he was like oh like because i
tied it to a weapon and the weapon
floated and i was like okay
i don't get the point of that and then
he was like oh maybe the weapon if you
have that attached to it and you're
holding it will help you float and you
won't sink i'm just like
yeah that might be possible i was i was
overhearing a conversation about that
and like it blew my mind like i'm never
gonna finish this game i feel like i
will always be playing it it's i think
you know something that's immediately
apparent is that you just have
you don't feel like you underst like
where so many games go out of their way
to me like are you sure you got
everything yeah you understand it all
right
you specifically like zelda games some
dude
hated how it did that coming off of
skyward sword this is such a i don't
want to say breath of fresh air but yes
um it's it's it's crazy
helmed by the same director too which
which kind of blows my mind yeah and
obviously like the fact that there's so
much detail in this game and so many
interlocking systems is probably a
testament to the fact that it's the
biggest team nintendo's ever had on a
project right yes and it's and it also
has incorporated monolithsoft who made
xenoblade chronicles and the world is
super evident of their their involvement
um it's great verticality
and you know even something as simple as
like uh you know
a large plane
will look
interesting even though just a huge
field of grass they managed to change
the elevation just the right ways and
there's been a lot of time and energy
put into even what seems like the most
basic elements of this game and i think
that's only possible when you do
something like
a company nintendo making the biggest
game they've ever made and that's the
thing about it it's
it's constantly reminding you not in a
bad way that yeah it's a zelda game but
i'm not thinking through it like i
usually do a zelda game usually a zelda
game i'm kind of the open world is just
there for to get to meet to the next
dungeon or to get the next the megaton
hammer or the fairy bow or the hook shot
in this i'm constantly thinking i'm
thinking do i have enough
uh like pepper soup or whatever it is to
make keep me warm when i'm going into
the mountains or else i'm gonna freeze
to death and you i have four hearts i'm
gonna be [ __ ] if i don't yeah that's
what i was gonna ask as we started this
conversation talking about like is it
more like are we excited because it's a
zelda game or because it's doing all
these interesting things and that's the
it's very different from how i would
normally approach
zelda like i i thought i had the
language of zelda down and then playing
this it's like oh i have to completely
learn a new
uh vocabulary to be able to play this
game yeah you know the first uh five
hours there are these shrines you go
into and they're these
tutorials
i mean they are kind of tutorials for
how you use the sheikah slate for the
powers it's like it's just a splash
screen right it's just a little thing
that says press this button to activate
this power and you figure it out that's
it in the dungeon yeah you figure yeah
but but but even it's like a tutorial
but it's not because
those dungeons are really shrines like
they grow in complexity over time so
yeah they start basic but it's certainly
not like anywhere near what skyward
sword was doing i want to keep talking
about this game forever uh we can talk
much more about it uh next week
um when your review is up after you'll
be up tomorrow yeah three a.m and rob
hillary and i will be doing a live
stream tomorrow at 8 a.m eight to 11
three hours right yeah cool we're just
gonna pacific time we're just gonna talk
about all the things i can't talk about
today but yes
i have a [ __ ] ton of questions i want to
get to because i would be remiss if i
did not don't be remiss mike
uh you mentioned degradable weapons
andrew jelly on twitter says do the
degradable weapons in breath of the wild
dampen the experience they're not as
fond of those types of mechanics and
games how do you feel about that um
it certainly feels strange at first uh
because zelda games you sort of always
measure your progress by what gear and
equipment you have right uh so to lose a
weapon that seems cool it's kind of like
oh man that's a bit of a bummer but you
have an endless supply of weapons and
because they they evolve over time like
in terms of where you are in the world
what's available in that particular
environment you get to use like a lot of
different stuff it's not just like four
swords i know it's title of zelda game
you know what i mean like it's not just
having a handful of swords to deal with
you are dealing with
i mean i've i have no idea how many
variations of weapons so yes the things
break but
um it's super fascinating to me just
that it doesn't actually impede on
the ex the experience because link is
struggling to do everything right and
you could argue that like well maybe
weapons don't need to break for him to
still struggle but like it's just that
extra little notch of just dialing it up
and making it making you have to
consider a little bit more um but you're
never out of weapons right you have the
bomb thing that you can use if you find
an enemy that has something when you
don't have any weapons throw a bomb on
him yeah they're not they're not a
limited quantity well they're limited in
that it's based on mana yeah yeah oh
yeah there's no no real mana to speak of
though right it's cool it's a cooldown
yeah sure um and yeah i felt i found
that the degradable weapons was
constantly changing my approach each
time like
i have this uh bokoblin club i can use
i'm like oh i'm set but then that breaks
the next camp i come up to i have a twig
uh maybe i could just smack them with it
or i could go up to this fire light it
and throw it at them to blow up these
barrels next to them which i might not
have done if i was just going to go in
with that bokoblin club yeah you're
forced to just sort of try things
differently all the time um that's a
great that's a great thing yeah uh i i
think the degradable weapons work i
would not have thought i would have said
that within a zelda game but i normally
don't like that yeah mechanic because
i'm just it's always like it seems
tedious but it works very well yeah um
because you're constantly managing your
invent like your resources and and
that's a big part of what you're doing
um and so it it goes very well with
what's already there versus some games
i'm like
okay i really
like my sword broke really okay i guess
i'm gonna go
do this thing that's
if the rest of the game is linear or
something it seems very unnatural and
this is very different right uh cd14 on
twitter was asking of all the 3d zeldas
which one is breath of the wild from the
first five hours that we've played most
reminiscent of
i didn't play a lot of twilight princess
because i couldn't get past that wolf
tutorial in terms of i just didn't want
to play it yeah um
you know i got a really strong vibe uh
similar to the way i felt when i played
ocarina of time um maybe not because of
the mechanical similarities or the
systems at play but it just
that sense of just like this is new like
this is new and exciting and you know
it's it feels like zelda but it's doing
things i've never really done in a zelda
game before like for ocarina of time
that was just being in 3d you know to a
point yeah um but here it's so much more
but it's that i get that same sense of
just amazement
it definitely recaptures that feeling
like i remember
playing ocarina of time and you see
death mountain in the distance and like
realizing you can go there
um was such a big deal and obviously now
it's you know it doesn't have replaying
it doesn't have that same feel because
we you know you can go there um but
uh that scene we saw earlier where
you're looking out and there's like a
mountain in the distance it's like
that feeling of ocarina of time times a
thousand yeah um and i love that it's
giving me that sense again of
i don't even know where i am i'm gonna
go yet but i'm gonna go over there i'm
gonna figure it out
maybe it's just me but i feel like this
zelda series has kind of been just like
spinning its tires for a while you know
what i mean like they introduced these
new mechanics like i think link between
worlds was
fantastic well sure that's awesome right
but but not something that is like
revolutionary sure right the way that
this seems to be like it's it's
i mean that game leaned quite heavily
into the fact that like
hey it's the old system but we've
tweaked it a little bit right you know
what i mean this is just kind of like
nothing old is here this is all new this
is very different based on the first
five hours it's almost like nintendo
didn't want to say what makes a zelda
game and how can we
iterate on that it seems like they asked
themselves
how do we change the definition of a
zelda game yeah yeah and that's super
exciting and i wish we could talk way
more about that but um
more specifically uh is it aiming in
breath of the wild on either platform
oh someone uh jai chi in the twitch chat
was asking uh this is coming to wii u
they asked yes it is um do we know when
the specific
yeah we have not tried it but yes uh jg
the twitch chat is coming to wii u um
but someone asks on either platform is
aiming on breath of the wild exclusively
reliant on the gyroscopic gyroscopic
functionality can you disable it uh you
can disable it yeah you can choose to
use it or not um i actually like to use
it on switch especially when i'm playing
in handheld mode um and with the pro
controller it helps too there are times
like when precision is necessary where
like
you're manipulating something using like
a magical power where it's like you
gotta get a weird angle and it's like
all right i'm now twisting my switch
like this i should just
use the analog stick yeah when i was
using the joy-con the frame controller
with the joy-cons on it i was aiming
with this analog stick but then when i
switched to the hmm
when i changed to the handheld tablet i
was using the gyroscope and i love that
it feels really good it feels like it
does on the 3ds
um
yeah i have a bunch of questions about
this um so
what are the consequences of death in
zelda i think a lot of people are
wondering is there like a dark
souls-esque thing or is it just a game
over and restarts it's just a game over
and you restart from one of the last of
many auto saves the game does a good job
of realizing like when you're entering
an area that might be threatening and
saving you know the game for you and you
can also just do like an old scale old
school zelda pause and save yes and
you're allowed once one slot for manual
saves
okay so you can't it's not like skyrim
where you can have a [ __ ] ton saved up
no yeah so you can just be like i messed
up i'm gonna start from this save right
so i like classic move which that i like
that though it
if i had a ton i would maybe go back
like 10 saves and then restart these
outposts then you're hacking the system
right then you're not really part of not
just you're not playing the adventure
the way it's meant to be yeah with one
say you have to rely on just the items
you have or at least that you did in
your last save and i like that yeah i
like that too um but then and then like
just a lot of questions in general uh
that last question the consequence of
death was george m
on twitter um
but yeah in general it it's almost it
just feels like a simulation game almost
and like how these mechanics can not
like a sim city or anything but how
these mechanics can interlock and how
these systems are kind of layered on top
of each other yeah there's a pretty good
physics model at play i've only played
five hours or i i played like four hours
we can only talk about the first five
hours but so far i feel like i'm
thinking constantly more than i do in
open world games i love horizon
i've been playing a lot of that but even
then i'm still kind of going through the
motions to get from point a to point b
if i'm not hunting an animal even when i
come across certain machines that i
fought before i'm going through the
motions i have this muscle memory and i
turn my brain off just play zelda i'm
constantly thinking so far yeah and
that's weird for a zelda game i mean you
know you go into dungeons and you do
puzzles and you're thinking constantly
right and like you know the water temple
or the fire temple or snowpeak ruins but
now i'm thinking like
i'm halfway off this cliff my stamina is
half drained it is cold so i need to
somehow get to a place where i can eat
this soup i cooked earlier that will
warm me up and resist the cold
uh
but i might fall off this cliff before i
get up there so now i'm battling i'm uh
balancing stamina and my cold my like
hypothermia i can get which is going to
deplete my health
i'm [ __ ] if i can't get up to the top
of this cliff in the next 10 seconds
you're like it's constantly like uh
you're weighing like opportunity cost of
things and and
um weighing like okay here's what i have
here's what i can cook here's what i can
do uh if i don't fall off this cliff
which i might yeah
yeah i know it's
it's you know some people are saying it
looks like it's more of an open world
survival game with zelda finish
but
to circle back for the end of the
segment to the question i was asking
before does it feel like a zelda game it
does to me
um kelly what about you yeah yeah i
would say so yeah there are story points
early in the game that we won't spoil
that i think
sets up a very zelda-like story yes yeah
and there's little touches as well that
are very familiar yeah i think people
feel at home despite all that's new and
strange around them puzzle solving there
are dungeons maybe now in the
traditional sense of you're going to go
to this one get this medallion then
you're going to have to go to gor uh
mount death mountain because we've been
told countless times you don't even need
to go through the dungeons right yeah
you can once you get off the first area
you can try to go right to gannon i mean
even when it's not it's crazy
right i want to see that even when it's
not uh similar to what we know about
zelda in terms of game player structure
it still to me has like the the spirit
and feel of zelda i think nintendo
generally does this really well as uh
giving like
a certain kind of charm and uh
characterization
with very minimal um like
without using words nintendo's really
good at that and so in that sense i i
feel even in the beginning
a lot more of zelda in that sense rather
than in structure
um i'm just reading this i don't know if
we have a new story up but apparently
the prototype for breath of the wild
back in the day started as an 8-bit game
at a gdc talk just now
uh breath of the wild director i might
be butchering this hidemaru fujibayashi
yeah revealed a prototype of the game
that looks remarkably like the original
8-bit rendition of legend of zelda but
with concepts introduced in breath of
the wild it was used as a proof of proof
of concept okay i can see that that
makes sense okay and that was uh the
verge just published that story i just
saw my twitter feed which that's cool
because i think this game is actually
kind of hewing closely to what made the
original legend of zelda great at that
time in 1987.
it certainly just like lets you loose
right with like
here you are like yeah what do i do go
here but you're gonna get [ __ ] up if
you don't have yeah this sword yeah
which is cool um you meet a hermit it
gives you a thing yes good luck talk to
an old man yeah gives you a hint we
would love to keep talking about this
game uh we could talk about it much more
after pete's review goes up tomorrow
morning 3am pacific time yes and check
for the video review on site and on
youtube and all that and then at 8 00
a.m to 11 a.m pacific pete and rob
handler will be playing
straight through three hours of it just
until they drop and everything is fair
game all restrictions are off so if you
want to talk about whatever yeah we're
kind of holding ourselves back now
especially pete because he's played so
much of it but tomorrow he will not have
to uh so the review will be up uh i'm
sorry if i didn't get to more questions
i wish we had more time uh keep sending
him
to pete bother him
uh sorry pete uh but yeah thank you for
everybody who sent them via twitter and
uh via twitch and the youtube chats i
appreciate it and let us know you think
if you're watching this uh on gamespot
after the fact or youtube we appreciate
the comments so now to segue into the
switch itself yeah jimmy
his review is up it's live mm-hmm what
uh
what do we give it we don't give scores
he gave it uh
there's no joke with the switch there
there's no easy one i don't know but
pete you've probably spent
the most time in the office with it
what's what's uh what's your overall in
a sentence
we're gonna talk more than a sentence
but right now hit me with the synopsis
uh the things that nintendo promised uh
aren't just marketing speak i definitely
felt myself experiencing these you know
like
great moments for having a console that
is both you know portable and something
you can play on your tv and i think it's
got great build quality and in terms of
technical performance like yeah it
doesn't stand up to playstation 4 xbox
one but
so far i don't care yeah for what it is
i think it's really good
i also think the amount of technology
they packed into the joy cons is really
impressive like the um
like i went to a gdc
switch thing and uh
the
rumble like the you can
get so many distinct sensations from it
hd rumble yeah it's like it's it's hard
to describe obviously because it's
definitely feeling based but um i was
really impressed with it uh just as far
as like i know nintendo just isn't
focused on um competing with the
technical prowess of of like ps4 or xbox
one which doesn't matter to me but i i
was really impressed with how they hold
up and like uh how good they feel to
hold i was really surprised because
they're so small i thought i was gonna
feel awkward with it and i didn't um so
i really like that too i like the
different controller options and there's
a reason to use all of them yeah
yeah i wouldn't say it's overwhelming
per se but i definitely you know
you first sit down just like any console
you first don't figure it out but with
this it's like okay i can play like a
handheld with the joycons on either side
of the tablet i can dock that and put
these in this like wireframe essentially
to play them that will also charge them
uh well you have to buy the one that
will charge them right we just have that
i can play with a pro controller i can
play if i want to play a multiplayer
game which have you done much with like
the holding the joy cons like by itself
played a little bit of snipperclips at
the new york event a couple weeks ago
okay um
but no i mean you know you've got games
like street fighter bomber man yeah
no one two switch isn't really like that
um but no the trailer showed people
playing like the next mario kart like
that right yeah it's
so in that sense it's not ideal
but that said it is it's a very sleek
solution for multiplayer that i think
people will you know
adapt to when the situation dictates
that hey let's play some games together
i don't want to have two big controllers
with me this is what we've got let's do
it yeah and i also um really like
playing in handheld i i really love
handheld gaming um probably because i'm
super nearsighted um and playing on tv
sometimes if text is small i get really
irritated but i also it's i thought
maybe it would be a little cumbersome i
love my 3ds and i love the size of it i
have an xl um and i thought maybe like
oh i'm gonna this is gonna be too big
for me to to really play handheld uh for
an extended period of time and i haven't
had that experience i've really enjoyed
it it's um super comfortable and uh i i
like having that option it's something i
thought would maybe feel gimmicky or
like oh i'm not actually going to use
this this way but uh i really am and i
like playing handheld actually probably
more than any other way i was taken
aback by how good it looks on the when
you're playing handheld i mean obviously
it's not it's not like 3ds graphics we
know it's better but i still like
pulling it out there's there's our tech
editor jimmy right now trying out but
i looked it i was playing breath of the
wild last night i had this moment where
i docked it and then i was like [ __ ] i
got to go make it i don't have pockets
that big
i don't that's
i'm not gonna put it in my pocket but
maybe he just i don't have nice khakis
like jimmy does but
uh
yeah this thing pete what are your
thoughts on the portability aspects i
think you said you played a fair amount
of breath of the wild in handheld right
yeah super comfortable to hold um it's
my preferred way to play zelda okay at
the moment um
but i've spent a lot of time with the
game so like i have this very personal
connection to it and just sort of like
tuck into a couch and like just be there
with it you know and right in front of
my face
that's pretty good yeah it's still just
as good on a tv you know but uh yeah in
terms of portability so far so good the
battery life
is basically about three hours
um
which i think is fair given what the
system is it's hard to compare it to
something like an iphone or a 3ds right
i mean this is running games
that i've never seen run this you know
zelda just looks incredible on this
playing in handheld mode and i've never
seen a game look that good on a portable
device before so
i mean we talked about this several
episodes ago about um you know games
that are made specifically for a
handheld that you're playing like 10 15
minutes at a time on your commute sorry
someone just switched someone someone in
the twitch chat uh forgive me if i
didn't see your name anytime i was like
zero access you said is that a nintendo
switch in your pocket are you just happy
to see me sorry
uh
kelly
never mind yeah i'm gonna look at her
for that i can call you out i'm sorry
like
it was funny after seeing jimmy put the
nintendo switch in his ice
okay so uh anyway
i don't even remember what i was saying
damn it yeah i'm so sorry i just saw
that it was i couldn't
um what was i talking about oh uh games
that are designed for handheld that you
play like on a commute and you can kind
of stop and start versus games that are
uh switch games are maybe more geared
towards uh you're not playing on the go
but you have the option to take it with
you and then set it up wherever your
destination is i think is the difference
buy a carrying case i can tell you i've
been using one for sure great i just put
it right in my backpack i don't worry
about it but yeah i'm scared for every
switch in the office it doesn't have a
screen protector or a case because i
think you're gonna get banged around
yeah i remember i was really nervous
putting in my backpack i was like uh i
put like a sweater around it and i'm
like trying i'm doing all these like low
tech hacks because i don't have a
carrying case right now yeah i put like
a breath of the wild t-shirt around it
that i found on my desk it was
appropriate that works what was like the
uh
kelly from your experience when you were
playing uh you said you prefer handheld
did you take it out or were you mainly
just going to different rooms in like
your apartment or something oh i was
just kind of hanging out in the house um
i
have been
i've been hesitant to take it out like
uh on the train be just because of
embargo stuff honestly i don't want
people to like bug me i don't want
people to talk to me uh when i'm on the
train uh for like any time i never want
people to talk to me yeah on the train
um or anytime uh but uh ever
okay
uh so i but i did i was so tempted uh
because i took a longer train than i
normally do the other day and i was like
i really want to take this out and play
and then i restrained myself but um for
the most part just taking it from the
office to my house to
a different room in the house is like i
just love that you know i don't have to
stop playing because i'm cooking
something yeah and my room is downstairs
and the kitchen's upstairs you know we
kind of touched on this already but
using breath of the wild there's like a
frame of reference how do things look
on the switch
i mean there's very little if any
anti-aliasing so you see some jaggies
but
that game's art style kind of drives um
well you know it's more than that though
it's the game support sucks when it does
chug it's because it's it's dealing with
a lot of like like physical logic in
terms of like okay well how do you move
through grass and how does wind affect
grass like those sort of things so it
actually looks technically impressive in
some ways but clearly it's a they're
striking a balance between
you know visual fidelity and frame rate
and all that
but i think i think it looks great yeah
i really like the ways all it looks on
it yeah like i said i was pretty
i liked how it looks a lot and handheld
and it felt pretty good in handheld the
one thing i noticed i don't know if this
was just like the switch i was using
the joy cons felt slightly loose when i
was holding in handheld like kind of
they didn't it didn't feel like one
thing it felt like i could tell they
were separate from the tablet a little
bit it wasn't like they were falling off
but they were a tiny bit like
yeah the one that we are sharing has is
like that but for the most part they
aren't like that okay yeah mine doesn't
feel okay i think maybe we didn't we
just put them in weird the reason you
broke it i it's my fault there's a time
where i found myself like wondering if
that was the case and i was kind of just
like twerking them a little bit yeah and
it was like i thought you said twerking
you said twerking well you thought you
said twerking you were twerking with
your hands
uh
and it was like okay if i really really
try i can feel this give but like under
normal circumstances i feel like this
thing is really sturdy that said don't
drop it i don't trust that the sort of
the latches are really that sturdy
um so you're gonna have to baby this
thing it's not gonna be like a phone you
can toss around in your 3ds i don't
think it'll be this like really durable
piece of equipment it's still
it's it's not it's still not a console
right but it's it's something you need
to be mindful of not everyone's as
strong as you though i mean yeah i'm a
real strong dude
you should also just take care of your
belongings i think sure uh
big blank spot in our knowledge of the
switch is like internet capabilities
right who knows uh calvin delaney on
twitter kiana just answered a question
but uh he said does the switch have a
way to sign into the internet on trains
or in hospitals
does it have a browser
uh there's no browser that i've seen but
what i do know that i can confirm which
i think is pretty rad is uh that it will
support like connections to networks
where you have to like go to a web page
to log in
so yes like maybe the hospital maybe the
hotel
here on our wi-fi network because we
can't for whatever reason get on certain
networks wirelessly
that'll work yes what do you think of
the like the home menu the browser in
general sorry it's like the console
browser slick right now but it's all
pretty basic like they're adding a few
things come launch day but i love the
little sound effects i love the little
animations it doesn't feel overburdened
like any other mobile device i'm used to
using it's cleaner than the 3ds it's
cleaner than the vita yeah it's just a
really slick interface that just has
what you need
cali you're saying
you prefer to play at handheld yeah
again but uh how did you feel like
actually switching between the tv and
the handheld like how fast was it how
responsive how
simple to use is it it didn't it wasn't
that difficult uh the
only thing i had trouble with is i
didn't read the instructions very well
and so it was like oh press l and r and
then a and i was just pressing l r
because i just didn't touch the handheld
yeah to get the um because i put the joy
cons in the uh kind of the boxy looking
controller configuration um which looks
a lot more uncomfortable than it is uh
like i said it's all it controls very
small but it's it feels a little small
but the controller configurations for
the most part all work for me pretty
well um depending on what i'm playing uh
but yeah that was just an error a user
error where i just didn't read the
instructions because i was
so excited to play but by and large you
know you but it's pretty darn like two
seconds later it's on your tv yeah it's
not it's pull it out and you're ready to
go super convenient and well i guess
that's not really the word i was looking
for it's it's
it doesn't feel cumbersome it doesn't
feel like a chore like so
i gotta get up and do this and then wait
for it to change it's just yeah it just
happens uh last question on twitter from
kirsten huston uh
kind of a future question do you think
nintendo will follow sony and
microsoft's lead in releasing like a
switch pro or something similar to that
absolutely yeah they have to right i
mean they already do that with
3ds also i mean like they they have a
presence there's a precedent for that
yeah but i think it's even more likely
now because they're working with nvidia
to make their chips and nvidia is a
company that goes through iterations of
their hardware and it's not like
nintendo has to have someone make really
like custom stuff for them right um
and i think the form factor will allow
you to replace something just like the
tablet or just the controllers without
having to do the whole package so i
would not be surprised in fact i expect
them
to do it yeah absolutely uh thank you so
much for everybody on twitter and twitch
and youtube and gamespot for getting in
your questions i wish we could answer
all of them i wish we had more time to
talk about zelda i wish we could talk
about the switch more i wish we could
even talk about horizon more but we
don't have time today uh we really
appreciate you stopping by just want to
reiterate uh we have
this mouse this razer uh death announce
for uh go to gamespot's twitter account
retweet the tweet about this giveaway
later on the week we'll pick a winner
it's u.s only i apologize uh and then
gunner
computer eyewear as it were these optics
to protect your eyes from harmful video
game
lasers i feel like i'm watching the
prices right i'm supposed to i know
guess how much
650. vanna white yeah one cent bob
uh and yeah as always everybody thank
you for joining uh thank you to the
people in the back eric tay jean luke
seyki and richard lee um we have the
zelda live stream tomorrow 8 a.m pacific
to 11 a.m pacific the review will be up
before that at 3 a.m pacific from this
here peter brown god willing yeah yeah
we have a lot of horizon coverage if
you're kind of holding off on the switch
uh we have the switch the review is up
on gamespot right now go check that out
uh jimmy our tech editor wrote that up
it is out in the wild now his thoughts
uh you know sans internet
it's out in the wild it's on the horizon
more puns
sweet so again everybody thanks for
joining uh hopefully we'll see you back
here later oh [ __ ] later on today at 2
30. we have a ralph cole antonio and
ricardo bear from
arcane studios are coming in to play
pray with me i'm gonna be hosting that
live stream at 2 30 uh p.m pacific
so come by i'm excited about that game i
want to check it out so stop by again
later on uh and then again zelda
tomorrow morning we hope to see you then
until then
2 30 today
have a good day
[Music]
all right
um